cubert
drewbert oh hubert
let's start on um how we first met
um do you remember
we actually didn't meet in person um
i uh i reached out to you oh my god you
did
you were so nice you were so nice
yes it was during the dark days of my
divine brown
scandal i was just an idiot
[Laughter]
i was a girl in our videos who got
caught by the police and i was back in
england
with five 000 members of the press
uh around the borders of my farm
and i opened a letter from you yes that
was very supportive and nice
and uh it was very cheering up
and i thought i i love drew barrymore
words of support from
uh an actress i didn't know in hollywood
was
lovely so i've always always have a
place in my heart
i loved you so much that whole incident
just
i related in my own life and i think
that
whether it's an actor or a politician or
anything in between
we expect people to be
infallible perfect
never flawed and god forbid we do
anything in our personal lives
that we would like to remain personal
but we don't have that privilege at a
certain point because
the cat gets let out of the bag and i
just uh had to reach out to you i just
appreciated you and i was so
i mean and you were just the most
charming human i
i loved getting to know you on our movie
music and lyrics and it's just one of my
very favorite movies and it makes me so
happy
it was a good movie it was a happy movie
it was a i agree with you
i i cause i love to hate the films i've
been in and i do hate some of them
but music and lyrics it's impossible to
hate
we're so good in it and so charming if
you
think i'm good in it that means a lot to
me because i have the deepest respect
for you beyond your charm
and you know your heart your talent
i mean is just unparalleled and you've
had a long body of work so you shan't
argue me out of that
hypothesis but it wasn't true
i think that film works maybe maybe we
acted quite well
but here's the weird thing we had
chemistry
and there were people i remember before
we shot that from it it's a bit
disgusting because he's 180
she's like 20. but actually
it we had a bit of chemistry we really
did
and it was funny too because when hugh
and i met
you know you you can be a bit of a
curmudgeon from time to time
um and uh and i
of course am like a labrador in heat and
like
i'm so excited with joy and so when we
both met we were like oh we're kind of
different people
like okay that is absolutely true
it was maybe that's why it had a bit of
crackle
and and then we really got to know each
other and accept each other for who we
were
and it became easy and then we just used
to sit around and laugh
that being said one of the moments that
i had some of the most
moxie um and i don't think we've ever
talked about this
i walked into i think it was like the
waverly
inn and this was
years ago and i'd had a few drinks
yes and i walked in and i ran into you
and instead of saying hello i grabbed
you by the collar and i fully started
kissing you
yes i remember that
[Laughter]
can i do your can i do you of what i saw
yes yes please you wait
i don't think that's true but if you
were like oh that like
the expression was you've never greeted
me that way before
and then and then you like had a second
thought and you were like
you know i'm not hating this and then
um and then we flirted and then it was
like we were like
okay yeah bye see you soon it was really
bizarre
i was very drunk as well and i was with
some
very nice but not drunk studio
executives from l.a they were very
surprised someone said oh there's drew
barrymore
i get up to say hi and then we make out
for 10 minutes and then i said no again
you go and talk about the script
well i guess we've grown up a bit do you
think growing up is overrated hubert
uh yeah i hate responsibility i
i don't want this i'm looking after five
children and a
elderly father and i don't like it i
i keep looking around for someone more
grown up to come and do it for me
and yet the last time we talked the way
that you
talk about the way you look at life now
having
five children's eyes to look through
look after and look into
you seem you know like
i'm i'm simultaneously
utterly exhausted and miserable and
clearly the happiest i've ever been i i
i see that now
it's so nice all those cliches are true
all that love is just so nice
i think that not just the children but
the wife as well
i have a top wife you'd be you are you
miss me so she's terrifying
uh swedish
much more manly than me in terms of
it but really cool and now you see i'm
happy
see i love that